[Música]
y yo elemento de revista de prensa de
nuestro espacio de francia 24 directo
américa ya está conmigo lista en el
estudio rosa pérez más de 2 rosa muy
buen día bienvenida hoy lunes 28 de
febrero quinto día guerra en ucrania las
portadas de los principales medios
internacionales continúan dedicadas a
este conflicto al este de europa rosa
repasamos entonces los titulares de la
jornada de hoy y empezamos en europa
buenos días raúl exactamente como
hicimos el viernes volvemos a repasar
las principales portadas empezamos en
europa con el medio británico the times
que dice putin pone la fuerza nuclear en
alerta mientras que el liberación dice
frente a putin todos a sus puestos este
medio este medio francés liberación
siempre tiene un grafismo no muy
espectacular y aquí vemos como tiene los
colores de la bandera de ucrania no sé
si lo estamos viendo en la pantalla creo
que no es el siguiente ahí lo tenemos y
pasamos a la vanguardia de españa y a la
repubblica de italia que también como
comentábamos a titular con esta quinta
jornada
bélica en ucrania putin desenfunda la
atómica esto que estábamos comentando en
los noticieros mientras que la
vanguardia dice putin pone en alerta
máxima el potencial nuclear de rusia
también con esta foto tan típica no de
cualquier escenario bélico raúl
así es rosa y ahora le pregunto entonces
como lo titula the final jam times y el
'global times' el financial times
empieza con mientras las conversaciones
en belarús están a punto de empezar que
de hecho ya empezaron hace un rato como
decíamos pues la guerra se recrudece y
por otro lado el 'global times' este
medio de china comenta en eeuu y la
unión europea anuncia en la exclusión
rusa del swift de este sistema
interbancario sos pensando pros y
contras cerramos ahora entonces con los
medios argentinos dos formas distintas
de encarar estas negociaciones rosa así
es porque mientras clarín dice dramática
negociación entre rusia y ucrania para
detener
página/12 pues parece que lo ve con una
chispa más de optimismo y comenta
precisamente una chispa de paz en medio
de la guerra y ahora cómo se analiza esa
situación desde kiev y desde moscú pues
mira raúl él quiere independent señala
que con una feroz defensa ucraína
frustra los planes de victoria relámpago
de rusia que si lo que moscú pretendía
era tomar rápidamente lo la capital de
momento no lo ha conseguido y que las
principales ciudades del país continúan
bajo el control de kiev por otro lado el
biliar este medio ruso señala por otra
parte que rusia tiene el control del
espacio aéreo ucraniano según el
ministerio de defensa de moscú y por
último el con sólo busca ya pravda se
pregunta qué significa esta orden de
putin o de tener en alerta pues a sus
armas de disuasión sus armas nucleares y
dicen básicamente explican que es el
penúltimo nivel el penúltimo estadio
antes del modo de disposición total de
combate en el que el botón rojo el botón
nuclear puede activarse en cualquier
momento y que después
de fuerza por parte de vladimir putin
rosa y que sucede entonces con la
agencia rusa estás pues mirad raúl
resulta que este mañana mientras
estábamos haciendo el habitual repaso de
la prensa nos hemos encontrado con que
esta agencia de noticias rusa estaba
hackeada por el grupo anonymous y si te
parece aquí estamos viendo una captura
del mensaje que se mostraba al entrar en
esta página lo traducimos para nuestros
espectadores decía queridos ciudadanos
les pedimos que paren esta locura no
manden a sus hijos y maridos a una
muerte segura putin nos miente y nos
pone en peligro estamos aislados del
mundo en unos años viviremos como en
corea del norte para qué nos sirve esto
para poner a putin en los libros de
historia esta no es nuestra guerra sin
embargo este mensaje ya no se encuentra
en la página ahora la última vez que
hemos entrado ya daba error pero hemos
creído que era muy importante no
destacar este hackeo este mensaje tan
directo de este grupo anonymus amos 100%
rosa pero que también antes de lo que
nosotros pudimos acceder a esta
información que te ofrecía esta agencia
sobre el bloqueo de google youtube los
medios estatales rusos y al bloqueo
también de rt y esto que anunció la
unión europea efectivamente antes de
este hackeo te comentaba que tanto
google como youtube impiden a los medios
estatales rusos como rusia today o
sputnik que hagan que accedan al dinero
que hacen con el sistema de anuncios de
estas páginas de youtube y google y por
otro lado rusia today se pregunta y la
libertad de expresión y de prensa y así
asegura que distintos periodistas se
solidarizan con rusia a today y con
sputnik tras el anuncio de ursula von
der leyen de la presidenta de la
comisión europea en la que el anuncio en
el que aseguró que pues la unión europea
está estudiando cómo bloquear la emisión
de estos medios pro estatales de estos
medios estatales rusos pues en el
territorio de la unión europea porque
ursula von der leyen calificó rusia
today o sputnik de por ejemplo
maquinaria mediática del crit kremlin y
de propagar información tóxica y dañina
en europa entre los periodistas que se
solidarizan con estos medios rusos
destacan pues la presidenta de telesur
pero sin embargo la amarga margarita
simonián
del grupo rusia today asegura que la
ópera lo que ellos llaman operación
especial no recordemos que no lo llaman
guerra pues va a continuar adelante a
pesar de que rusia today opere uno en el
continente o rápidamente rosa vamos a
cerrar con la descripción ilustrada de
la situación con las caricaturas en the
guardian le monde y el país así es mira
raúl cuando las caricaturas son buenas
no hace falta ni añadirle ni añadirles
palabras así es empezamos con la de ven
jennings en the gardian no pues la
imagen lo dice todo no aquí las tropas
rusas frente a una chica con un
tirachinas vestido con el color de
ucrania seguimos con la viñeta que
encontramos en limón que no es de hoy
simplemente este periódico recoge una
dieta que ya se publicó a lo largo del
mes de febrero y dice dicen que es un
convoy de la libertad o algo así una
retórica muy recurrente en los
escenarios bélicos aquí pues un puesto
fronterizo ucraniano y las tropas rusas
llegando isla habitaba enana en el país
también dice una guerra y crítica
no está doble vara de medir con
distintos conflictos porque alguien
señala esta vez es una guerra ilegal
como si al final la población civil no
sufriera sea quien sea el invasor y las
víctimas más afectadas como siempre los
civiles lamentablemente rosa muchísimas
gracias como siempre por toda la revista
de prensa mañana nos vemos con más
nosotros vamos a saludar a nuestro
primer invitado del día